hey Kelly yeah well I see my Kelly  Clarkson to present I'm aware I just  don't care I'm still about Christmas I  know we saw up Halloween and November  like you know Thanksgiving but I've  already moved on I've got every present  but one I hate that my feet dangle must  be nice to sit in a chair John and your  feet touch the floor guys don't ever  pick me this is like junior high all  over again it's like I wear repellent  they're just like that's real cute right  no I mean I can't say any of these to  happen to me thank you for being a  gentleman thank you for being gentleman  to the table why would I stood up return  hello I love this young so good usually  I'm just like hey all right way than I  think it's me and it's looking so good  somebody else but me I hate y'all  me oh hi  I'm not even gonna turn around for men  I'm done i crying about it I just think  it's hardness man don't pick me I'm fun  taste in music write that down  [Applause]  [Music]